the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
in this video i will be reading one of
the stories from george r martin's most
recent book fire and blood
as you all know hbo is working on a new
show house of the dragon which is based
on what is written
in this book unfortunately i don't think
we will see this character in the new
show
because she died long before any of the
events surrounding the dance of dragons
since i know a lot of you haven't read
any of the books you might not be that
familiar with this character
how she dies has to be one of the most
horrific ways to die in all of the song
of ice and fire
what exactly happened to area targaryen
is still a mystery till this day
there are many different theories about
her death so i want to read what it says
in fire and blood then at the end of the
video
let me know what you think down below i
highly recommend watching the entire
video because what it says about
belarion the black dread
is actually kind of frightening when you
think about it this is what it says
about the day
area targaryen arrived back in king's
landing
everyone remembers what they were doing
when they heard the blast of a horn
ringing through the morning
air the sound of it ran down my spine
like a cold knife
the queen would say later though i could
not have said why
in a lonely watchtower overlooking the
waters of blackwater bay
a guard had glimpsed dark wings in the
distance and sounded the alarm
he sounded the horn again as the wings
grew larger
and a third time when he saw the dragon
plane black against the clouds
belarion had returned to king's landing
it had been long years since the black
dread had last been seen
in the skies above the city and the
sight filled many a king's lander with
dread
wondering if somehow megar the cruel had
returned from beyond the grave to mount
him once again
alas the rider hanging onto his neck was
not a dead king but a dying child
valerion's shadow swept across the yards
and halls of the red keep as he came
down
his huge wings buffeting the air to land
in the inner yard by maegor's holdfast
scarcely had he touched the ground then
princess aria slid from his back
even those who had known her best during
her years at court scarce recognized the
girl
she was near enough to naked as to make
no matter
her clothing no more than rags stuck to
her arms and legs
her hair was tangled and matted her
limbs as thin as sticks
please she cried to the knights and
squires and serving men who had seen her
descend
then as they came rushing toward her she
said
i never ian collapsed sir lukamore
strong had been at his post on the
bridge across the dry moat surrounding
maegor's holdfast
shoving aside the other onlookers he
lifted the princess in his arms and
carried her
across the castle to grand maester
benefer later he would tell anyone who
had listened that the girl was flushed
and burning with fever
her skin so hot he could feel it even
through the enameled scale of his armor
she had blood in her eyes as well the
knight claimed
and there was something inside her
something moving that made her shudder
in my arms
he did not tell those tales for long
though the next day
king jiharis sent for him and commanded
him to speak no more of the princess
the king and queen were sent for at once
but when they reached the maester's
chambers
benefer denied them entry you do not
want to see her like this he told them
and i would be remiss if i allowed you
any closer
there were guards posted at the door to
keep servants away as well
only septon barth was admitted to
administer the rights for the dying
benefit did what he could for the
stricken princess giving her milk of the
poppy
and immersing her in a tub of ice to
bring her fever down
but his efforts were to no avail the sun
had set
and the hour of the bat was at hand when
barth emerged to announce that area
targaryen was dead
the princess was consigned to the flames
the very next day at sunrise
her body wrapped in fine white linen
from head to toe
grand maester benefer who had prepared
her for the funeral pyre
looked half dead himself the king
announced that his niece had died of a
fever
and asked the realm to pray for her
king's landing mourned for a few days
before life resumed as before
and that was the end of it mysteries
remained however
even now centuries later we are no
closer to knowing the truth
more than 40 men have served the iron
throne as grand maester
their journals letters account books
memoirs
and court calendars are our single best
record of the events they witnessed
but not all of them are equally diligent
whereas some left us volumes of letters
full of empty words
never failing to note what the king ate
for supper and whether he enjoyed it
others set down no more than a half
dozen missives a year
in this regard benefer ranks near the
top and his letters and journals provide
us with detailed accounts of all that he
saw
did and witnessed well in service to
king jaharis and his uncle maegor before
him
and yet in all of benefer's writings
there is not a single word to be found
concerning the return of aria targaryen
and her stolen dragon to king's landing
nor the death of the young princess
fortunately septon barthe was not so
reserved
and it is to his own account we must now
turn
the septon wrote it has been three days
since the princess
perished and i have not slept i do not
know that i shall ever sleep again
the mother is merciful i have always
believed
and the father above judges each man
justly
but there is no mercy and no justice in
what befell our young princess
how could the gods be so blind or so
uncaring as to allow such horror
i do not know i do not want to know if
this makes me a faithless septon then so
be it
grand maester benefer and i have agreed
to tell no one at all of what we saw
and experienced in his chambers as that
child lay dying
not the king nor the queen nor her
mother
nor even the archmaesters of the citadel
but the memories will not leave me
so i shall set them down here mayhaps by
the time they are found in red
men will have gained a better
understanding of such evils
we have told the world that princess
aria died of a fever
and that is broadly true but it was a
fever such as i have never seen before
and hope never to see again the girl was
burning
her skin was flushed and red and when i
laid my hand upon her brow to learn how
hot she was
it was as if i had thrusted into boiling
oil
there was scarce an ounce of flesh upon
her bones
so gaunt and starved did she appear but
we could observe
certain swellings inside her as her skin
bulged out and then sunk down again as
if
no not as if for this was the truth of
it
there were things inside her living
things that were moving
mayhap searching for a way out and
giving her such pain that even milk of
the poppy gave her no relief
we told the king as we must surely tell
her mother
that aria never spoke but that is a lie
i hope that i
shall soon forget some of the things she
whispered through her cracked and
bleeding lips
i cannot forget how often she begged for
death
all the maester's arts were worthless
against her fever
if indeed we can call such a horror by
such a commonplace
name the simplest way to say it is that
the child was cooking from within
her flesh grew darker and darker and
then began to crack
until her skin resembled nothing so much
7 save me as pork cracklings
smoke issued from her mouth her nose
even
most obscenely from her nether lips or i
should say
her lips down below by then she ceased
to speak
though the things within her continued
to move her very eyes
cooked within her skull and finally
burst like two eggs that were left in a
pot of boiling water for far too long
i thought that was the most hideous
thing that i should ever see
but i was quickly disabused of that
notion
for a worse horror that was awaiting me
that came when benefer and i lowered the
child
into a tub and covered her with ice the
shock of that immersion stopped her
heart at once
i tell myself if so that was a mercy
for that was when the things inside her
came out mother have mercy
i do not know how to speak of them they
were
worms with faces snakes with hands
slimy unspeakable things that seemed to
squirm as they came bursting from her
flesh
some of them were no bigger than my
little finger but one was at least as
long as my arm
they died though i must remember that
hold on to that
whatever they might have been they were
creatures of heat and fire
and they did not love the ice oh no one
after another they thrashed and died
before my eyes
thanked the seven i will not presume to
give them names
they were [ __ ] the first part of
septon bars accounts
ends here but some days later he
returned and resumed
arya targaryen is gone but not forgotten
the faithful prey for her sweet soul
every morn
and every night outside the seps the
same questions are on every lip
the princess was missing for more than a
year where could she have gone
what could have happened to her what
brought her home
was belarion the monster believed to
haunt the velvet hills of andolus
could the black dread have flown as far
as astapor to be the dragon in the pit
no and no and no these are fables
if we set aside such distractions
however
the mystery remains where did aria
targaryen go
after fleeing dragonstone queen reina's
first thought was that she had flown to
king's landing
when that proved wrong reina next looked
to the fair isle and old town
both made sense after a fashion but area
was not to be found at either location
nor anywhere in westeros others
including the queen and myself
took this to mean that the princess had
flown east not west
and would be found somewhere in essos
the girl might well have thought the
free cities to be beyond her mother's
grasp
and queen alisan in particular seemed
convinced that arya was fleeing her
mother
as much as dragonstone itself yet lord
rhaego's agents
and informers could find no hint of her
across the narrow sea
nor even a whisper of her dragon why
though i can offer no certain evidence i
can suggest an
answer it seems to me that we all have
been asking the wrong question
aria targaryen was still well shy of her
13th name day
on the morning she slipped from her
mother's castle though she was no
stranger to dragons
she had never ridden one before and for
reasons we may never understand
she chose belarion as her mount instead
of any of the younger and more tractable
dragons she might have claimed
as driven as she was by her conflicts
with her mother mayhem
she simply wanted a beast larger and
more fearsome than queen reina's dream
fire
it might have also been a desire to
mount the beasts that had slain her
father
and his own dragon though arya had never
known her father
and it is hard to know what feeling she
might have had about him
and his death regardless of her reasons
the choice was made
she might well have intended to fly to
king's landing just as her mother
suspected
it might have been her thought to seek
out her sister in old town
or to go seeking after lady alyssa
farman who had once promised to take her
adventuring
whatever her plans were they did not
matter it is one thing to leap upon a
dragon
and quite another to bend him to your
will especially a beast as old and
fierce as the black dread
from the very start we have asked where
did arya take belaryon
what we should have been asking was
where did belarion take area
only one answer makes sense recall if
you will
that belarion was the largest and oldest
of the three dragons that king aegon
and his sisters rode to conquest vegar
and maraxis had hatched on dragonstone
belarion alone had come to the island
with anor the exile
and danis the dreamer the youngest of
the five dragons they brought with them
the older dragons had died during the
intervening years but valerion lived on
growing ever larger fiercer and more
willful
if we discount the tales of certain
sorcerers and mount banks
as we should he is perhaps the only
living creature in the world that knew
valyria before the doom
and that is where he flew the child who
was desperately trying to hold onto his
back
what befell her on valyria i cannot
surmise
judging from the condition in which she
returned to us i do not even care to
contemplate it
the valyrians were more than dragon
lords they
practiced blood magic and other dark
arts as well
delving deep into the earth for secrets
best left buried
for these sins the gods in their wrath
struck them down
valyria is accursed all men agree and
even the boldest sailor steers well
clear of its smoking bones
but we would be mistaken to believe that
nothing lives there now
the things we found inside area
targaryen live there now
i would submit along with such other
horrors as we cannot even begin to
imagine
i have written here at length of how the
princess died
but there is something else something
even more frightening
that requires mention belarion the black
dread has wounds
as well that enormous beast the black
dread
the most fearsome dragon ever to soar
through the skies of westeros
returned to king's landing with
half-heeled scars that no man recalled
ever having seen before
in a jagged rent down his left side
almost nine feet long
a gaping red wound from which his blood
still dripped
hot and smoking the lords of westeros
are proud men
in the septons of the faith and the
maesters of the citadel
in their own ways are proud or still but
there is much and more of the nature of
the world that we do not understand
and may never understand the father made
men curious
some say to test our faith it is my own
abiding sin
that whenever i come upon a door i must
need see what lies upon the farther side
but certain doors are best left unopened
area targaryen went through such a door
septum bar's account ends here he would
never again mention the fate of aria
targaryen
in any of his writings and even these
words would be sealed away
to remain undiscovered for almost 100
years
so what do you think happened to area
targaryen
and even blarey on the black dread did
something attack them
was she infected by some disease does it
have anything to do with blood magic
leave me your thoughts down below and as
always i want to thank everyone for
watching
the video have a great day everyone i
will see you again
very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
you